the Nazis used gas to kill millions in
concentration camps Nazi scientists also
test toxic chemical weapons on their
prisoners
[Music]
after the war military investigators
discover vast Nazi stockpiles of novel
chemical weapons the Allies need to
dispose of these lethal toxins urgently
they choose the murky depths of the
Baltic Sea the British and the Soviet
Union dump 65,000 tons of Nazi chemicals
they've seized right into the Baltic for
this beautiful emerald swirl and the
Baltic Sea actually be a toxic stew of
chemical weapons used by the Nazis
during the Second World War
allied scientists seal the lethal
chemicals in metal barrels in a vain
attempt to prevent corrosion from the
Baltic saltwater
but it's not enough this is an enormous
amount of chemicals and and it's gonna
come out at some point this noxious Nazi
cloud of poison the team of specialized
divers recently discovers traces of
mustard gas on the seabed now scientists
are examining the sunken Nazi stockpile
to check for wider contamination it
really would be an environmental
catastrophe but when marine biologists
examine the satellite image they believe
the green vortex is not the result of
Nazi chemical wonder weapons but they
think it's something potentially just as
deadly a plague of killer microbes so
what's really going on here
it's actually an algebra on the Baltic
Sea if this is the case it's deeply
disturbing these algae blooms can be
just as dangerous or toxic as any
released Nazi chemical weapons
billions of organisms will to create a
deadly toxic vortex as large as 145
thousand square miles the natural
currents on the baltic take this algae
and cause these swirls and eddy currents
that make up this beautiful geometric
patterns that looks like a swirling
vortex and the algae suffocates all life
in its path these algae blooms take all
the dissolved oxygen out of the water
creating these huge dead zones and it
can be very very devastating to the
surrounding area where it occurs to some
marine biologists this green is the
color of death
[Music]